[Música]
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg pidió a los países de la
alianza atlántica que entreguen a
Ucrania nuevos sistemas de defensa aérea
tras la escalada de la ofensiva rusa
precisamente hoy Rusia volvió a
bombardear las ciudades sapurilla
Tenemos reporte desde Bruselas el
sindicato cgt aseguró que llevará ante
los tribunales la medida del gobierno
francés que obliga a los trabajadores en
paro a volver al trabajo la huelga de
los empleados de las refinerías Ha
generado un gran desabastecimiento de
combustible
hoy el 12 de octubre se conmemora en
gran parte de América y en España la
llegada de Cristóbal Colón al continente
americano una llegada que dio pie a la
colonización española del continente por
lo que celebrar la fecha es motivo de
malestar entre gran parte de la
población que recuerda el genocidio de
los pueblos indígenas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania en
Bruselas se celebra la primera reunión
de la otan desde la anexión a Rusia de
los territorios de lugansk jerson y
saporiya en el encuentro el secretario
general de la organización jeans
stoltenberg agradeció a los miembros de
la alianza atlántica el envío de nuevos
sistemas de defensa antiaéreos a kiev
ante la escalada de la ofensiva rusa
recordemos que tras la explosión del
sábado en el puente de crimea de la que
Rusia acusa Ucrania el lunes las fuerzas
de Moscú lanzaron un ataque masivo con
81 misiles sobre todo el territorio
ucraniano incluida la capital kiev como
resultado al menos 20 personas murieron
y decenas de civiles resultaron heridos
nuestra corresponsal en Bruselas Esther
Herrera nos ampliaba previamente sobre
las decisiones de la otan para reforzar
su apoyo a Ucrania
los ministros de la otan hoy han querido
enviar un mensaje muy claro van a ayudar
a Ucrania pase lo que pase lo que pase
el secretario general de la otan y en
stoltenberg asegurado que ahora mismo la
prioridad es ayudar a Ucrania con
sistemas de defensa antiaérea algo que
se ha visto muy claramente en estos
últimos ataques por parte de Rusia de
los últimos días en territorio ucraneal
en este sentido stoltenberg agradecido
la ayuda de Estados Unidos y también de
Alemania en que se han enviado este tipo
de sistemas de defensa recientemente De
hecho también el Secretario de Defensa
de Estados Unidos y hoy Austin ha
asegurado que este tipo de ayuda tanto
la urgente como la de más a largo plazo
va a seguir enviándose a Ucrania con
toda la ayuda que sea necesaria
justamente hoy además los ministros de
defensa de la otan se han reunido con su
homólogo ucraniano o Lexi reshnikov que
se ha podido escuchar de primera mano
Cuáles son las necesidades de Ucrania en
materia militar
otros países en la reunión han asegurado
que ya han anunciado nuevos compromisos
de ayuda militar a Ucrania por ejemplo
Canadá ha anunciado 30 millones de
dólares en un nuevo equipamiento militar
pero también Países Bajos en que seguirá
ayudando con formación y también
sistemas de defensa de cohetes
y en Nueva York continúa las sesión
especial de la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas donde se debate
precisamente la anexión a Rusia de los
territorios de idóneas gerson y saporiya
recordemos que la integración de estos
territorios se basa en el resultado de
refrendos no reconocidos por la
comunidad internacional el voto de la
moción de condena las anexiones será
público lo que revelará los apoyos con
los que cuenta el kremlin a estas
alturas de la guerra
y Mientras tanto en Moscú el ejército
ruso rindió homenaje a sus soldados
caídos en la Guerra de Ucrania con el
lema Gloria a los héroes como les
decíamos Rusia ha intensificado sus
ataques aéreos pero a pesar de la
movilización de reservistas pierde
control sobre el terreno Andrés
granadillo nos tiene los detalles
un homenaje a los soldados caídos en
combate fotos en las calles de podolsk A
las afueras de Moscú las autoridades
rusas apoyan a su ejército en los
carteles se lee Gloria a los héroes de
podolsk en las imágenes están Iván muray
y Valery quienes murieron el territorio
ucraniano en esta nueva fase de la
guerra Rusia llamó a unos 300.000
reservistas el pasado 21 de Septiembre
el mayor número desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial
estamos hablando de una movilización
parcial es decir solo estarán sujetos al
servicio militar los ciudadanos que
estén actualmente en la reserva y sobre
todo aquellos que sirvieron en las
fuerzas armadas y tengan ciertas
especialidades militares y experiencias
relevante
la mayoría de los reclutados son
voluntarios el anuncio causó que los
hombres llamados al combate intentaran
salir para la vecina Georgia en unas
filas que parecían interminables el
ministro de defensa ruso afirmó cian el
listado más de la mitad
desde el 21 de Septiembre se ha llevado
a cabo una movilización parcial en el
país a día de hoy más de 200.000
personas han entrado en el ejército
a pesar de esta nueva estrategia los
ataques por parte de la contraofensiva
ucraniana ha devuelto El dominio sobre
algunas ciudades que estuvieron bajo
control ruso durante meses según el
Washington post que cita el medio ruso
media zona hasta Julio unos 5.100
soldados habrían muerto en Ucrania pero
la inteligencia estadounidense dice que
podrían llegar a los 15.000 vamos ahora
a Francia porque el Sindicato de
trabajadores cgt afirmó que impugnará
ante la justicia la decisión del
gobierno de obligar a trabajadores en
huelga a volver a sus puestos de trabajo
en el depósito de la petrolera Epson
Mobile en normandía tras semanas de
escasez causada por los paros de en
refinerías tanto de Epson como de total
donde continúan las movilizaciones el
sindicato alega que El Ejecutivo vulnera
así el derecho a la huelga Marta Moya
con los detalles
el gobierno francés ha cumplido sus
amenazas los empleados en huelga de este
depósito de exxon Mobile tendrán que
volver al trabajo o enfrentarse a
sanciones penales los enfurece porque se
está violando nuestro derecho a la
huelga desde el principio a nuestro
movimiento ha sido Pacífico obviamente
nosotros cgt En cuanto tengamos estas
demandas presentaremos denuncias a
través de nuestros abogados por el
momento la obligación a trabajar no se
refiere a las actividades de la
refinerías y por tanto a la producción
de combustible
pero el objetivo es permitir el
transporte de la gasolina que ya está
almacenada allí 6 de las siete
refinerías seguían cerradas el miércoles
algunas desde hace más de dos semanas
está previsto que el gobierno realice
otra requisiciones en los próximos días
el impacto este conflicto social se ha
alargado y somos conscientes de ello Es
algo insoportable para demasiado
franceses
algunos de los cuales se les impide ir a
trabajar llevar a sus hijos al colegio
mientras las filas en las gasolineras se
alargan en toda Francia en algunos
departamentos los prefectos dan
prioridad a los vehículos de emergencia
y a los cuidadores una medida que no a
todo el mundo le gusta esta es la
tercera estación de servicio en la que
he estado Así que hemos estado luchando
desde esta mañana desde las 7 de la
mañana estoy en la calle ante la
probabilidad de que continúe la escasez
cada vez más sindicatos de las llamadas
profesiones esenciales exigen un acceso
prioritario
en otras noticias en Irán continúen las
protestas desatadas por la muerte de
maxa Amin bajo custodia de la policía de
la moral el 16 de septiembre desde
entonces la muerte de la joven de 22
años ha desencadenado un movimiento
masivo contra el régimen de Teherán ya
son cuatro semanas de manifestaciones en
medio de la represión mortal que ejerce
la fuerza pública así como de cortes de
las comunicaciones y de internet
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal enteran Catalina Gómez
Ángel sobre el desarrollo de la
situación
por lo que se puede leer en esos
mensajes que circulan en las redes
sociales esta nueva jornada de protestas
un mensaje más al Estado iraní de que
estás movilizaciones no van a parar ya
casi se cumple estamos A pocas horas de
que se cumpla un mes de la detención de
esta joven curda maxa eran por la
policía la moral horas después sería
llevada al hospital con muerte cerebral
también una de las razones para la
convocatoria del día de hoy se debe a la
gran represión que estamos viendo en las
últimas horas en el kurdistán iraní esto
viene dándose desde el comienzo desde
pocas horas después de la muerte de
maxamos que ella es kurda allí empezaron
las protestas no solamente en su ciudad
sagués sino en la capital del kurdistán
iraní en San Andrés Donde ha habido una
gran represión de las autoridades sin
embargo esta se ha aumentado según se ha
conocido y a pesar de las restricciones
de internet en los últimos tres días no
se sabe el número de Muertos pero se
dice que hay bastantes las personas
heridas se habla de Gran presencia de
las autoridades no solamente en San
anddash sino en maribán una población
fronteriza con el kurdistán iraquí es
que irán acusa a dos grandes grupos
opositores kurdos iraníes con base en
Irak de estar moviendo esas protestas
dentro del país una organización de
Derechos Humanos iraníes que opera en
oslo habla de 201 personas muertas hasta
el momento y dice que muchos de esos
serían en el kurdistán iraní Pero eso
también llegan un momento en el que el
estado el iraní intenta crear lazos o
por unos puentes de comunicación con la
población hoy veíamos Cómo eran está
llena de pancartas con la bandera de
Irán y hablan de la unidad de Irán Y a
ella versiones dentro de algunas
autoridades que hablan de crear diálogos
puntos de encuentro pero hoy el líder
supremo volvía y se refería a estas
protestas como pequeños movimientos
aislados que estaban siendo desde el
extranjero
cambiamos de tema el 12 de octubre de
1492 Cristóbal Colón llegó a América lo
que desencadenó en la colonización
española del continente más de 500 años
después la fecha sigue causando
controversia por Cómo debe ser
conmemorada en Guatemala en este día el
movimiento anti racista encabezado por
mujeres indígenas denuncia el
persistente racismo institucional en el
país nuestros corresponsales auror bayod
y Andrés Suárez nos traen la historia
vinieron de Ecuador México Colombia
Honduras 500 mujeres indígenas de todo
el continente se reunieron en Guatemala
para enfrentar juntas las políticas de
exclusión que sufren desde hace 230 años
y la celebración por la llegada de
Cristobal Colón a américa no entro en la
agenda de la Cumbre parte de esa
política
institucionalizada de del racismo que
existe en nuestro país es querernos
decir de que el 12 de octubre es el día
que nos descubrieron que a partir del 12
de octubre empezó la civilización en
nuestros estados para nosotros el 12 de
octubre ha sido uno de los días más más
crueles más oscuros de nuestra historia
el país anfitrión cuenta con un 50% de
mallas garifunas y afrodescendientes y
dentro de esos pueblos la pobreza es
300% más fuerte que en el resto de pero
la mayor exclusión la viven las mujeres
por vestir la ropa que las identifican
como indígenas las que hemos venido
luchando somos las mujeres porque somos
las víctimas de esta discriminación por
lo que encontraron en el uso de sus
trajes una manera de resistir o sea todo
el proceso de colonización en Guatemala
hace un proceso de desingenización Y
entonces mucha gente se avergüenza o
muchos Perdieron el idioma la
indumentaria nosotras debemos en
nuestros tejidos como parte de nuestros
territorios que hay que defender en el
municipio de Santiago Zacatepec que es
donde solo las abuelas seguían Tejiendo
ese arte retomó fuerza Verónica es una
de las nuevas alumnas a punto de
aprender a tejer los diseños ancestrales
nuestras abuelas y abuelos lucharon día
con día para que prevalezcan nuestro
tejido cada hilo cada color representa y
el esfuerzo sobre todo la historia de
nuestro pueblo
y 530 años después del día en que cambió
por completo la historia de sus
ancestros indígenas Estas mujeres aún
resisten el racismo a base de hilos y
memoria
precisamente previamente conversamos con
la historiadora Valentina Mena de la
Universidad javeriana de Bogotá sobre el
enfoque que deberíamos darle a la
conmemoración del 12 de octubre
escuchemos
bueno como tal festivo significa que
habría una festividad Y en este caso no
sería una festividad porque
históricamente pues este día nació en
1913 cuando el exministro español
Faustino Rodríguez San Pedro decidió en
la como presidente de la unión
iberoamericana crear esta idea del día
de Colón para unir España y América cuál
es el problema al problema es que si tú
lo llamamos como celebración entonces
hay que celebrar que Colón llegó a
América eso desencadenó una serie de
matanzas de enfermedades y de cuestiones
que hoy en día están revaluadas entonces
celebración como tal No pero sí es una
conmemoración de que ocurrió este hecho
de la colonización y que varios pueblos
indígenas también la esclavitud se
originó a raíz de esto
y la NASA anunció que el 14 de noviembre
volverá a intentar el lanzamiento de la
misión artemis 1 destinada a llenar el
camino para el regreso de la humanidad a
la luna recordemos que la agencia
estadounidense ha tenido que posponer ya
tres veces la partida de la misión dos
veces por razones técnicas y otra por
causas meteorológicas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Frank 34 y 34.com
[Música]